Good morning. Hank. It's Tuesday, November 12, 2013. 11/12/13!
I learned an interesting fact today, which is that
sugar does not make children hyperactive.
Now I know what you're saying, Hank: Yes, it does.
Because you remember being a kid and drinking a Coke
and then you and I would like, run around in circles
for hours and hours and hours
-- hold on I have to button up this button. What are we shooting here, some kind of swimsuit catalog?
But it doesn't, Hank! Sugar does not cause hyperactivity, and there are more studies attesting to this
than there are studies proving that like,
most drugs humans take are safe.
You know, on second thought, I think I need to
come down a button after all.
[Henry] Woah!
[John] Oh hey, Henry!
Anyway, if you don't believe me you should watch
this Healthcare Triage video by Dr. Aaron Carroll.
Dr. Carroll helps write a blog
called Incidental Economist
-- that I stole from a lot in my video
about healthcare costs --
and then it turns out that he lives in Indianapolis,
so we met and now we are producing a show
that he's making about healthcare
that adds like, nuance and
complexity to the conversation.
You know, all the things that
traditional healthcare reporting is lacking.
So if you want understand like drug trials and insurance and why sugar highs are not actually caused by sugar,
you should check out Healthcare Triage. You can click here or else there's also a link in the doobly-doo.
Anyway, Dr. Carroll also writes books
which I have read two of in the last 24 hours because they are highly addictive,
and also because they have revealed that my entire life is a lie.
Like, for instance, teething does not cause babies to have fevers.
Married people have more sex than single people of the same age, and also report that the sex they have is better.
Using a sponge to clean your kitchen counter will likely make your kitchen counter dirtier than it was before
because the average sponge contains more pathogens than like, the average toilet seat.
Lifting heavy boxes does not cause hernias.
It can reveal hernias, but it doesn't cause them.
Americans are not more likely to commit suicide
around Christmas.
If you stop exercising your muscles do not turn to fat, which is good news from my emerging guns.
Also, as you gain weight, the number of fat cells
in your body doesn't increase;
it's just that the *size* of them increases.
Sit-ups do not flatten your stomach.
And in great news for me you are not more likely to get an infection from being on an airplane
than from being in any other public space,
like an office building or a bus or whatever.
But you are more likely to acquire a disease
in any of those places
than you are if you just like stay in your house
by yourself, so thank you Internet!
Also, Hank, I learned that in rare instances
vomiting hard and frequently
can cause your eyes to pop out of your head.
So that's a good thing for a hypochondriac
like myself to know
because it ensures that for the rest of my life I will be puking with my eyes closed.
Okay, Henry. So Daddy cannot eat worm pizza, your first
suggestion for the gross thing I should eat,
because it turns out eating worms can be
really bad for you. It can be kind of poisonous.
[Henry] Why?
Well, 'cause they have bacteria on them.
[Henry] Oh.
Those little microbes. You know?
[Henry] Yeah.
Yeah, so we can't eat them.
[Henry] Okay, but--
So what gross thing should I eat
for my punishment?
[Henry] Ah, you're gonna eat slobber carrots!
Slobber carrots, what are those?
[Henry] No, how about I drool on them?
You're gonna drool on slobber carrots?
[Henry] Yeah.
And then I have to eat it?
[Henry] Mm-hmm.
Henry, wasn't there something else
that you wanted me to eat?
[Henry] Really gross barbecue!
Really gross barbecue?
[Henry] Yeah.
What does that mean?
[Henry] I don't know about that.
We're gonna make it--
are we gonna make it gross together?
[Henry] No.
[Henry] I know how to make it gross! Put my drool!
[laughs] So we're gonna have slobber carrots with Henry drool and really gross barbeque with Henry drool.
[Henry] Yeah. How about wooden shoes?
A wooden shoe?!
[Henry] Yeah.
[Henry] No?
I mean, I don't think I can eat--
I might be able eat a little part of a wooden shoe.
[Henry] No, not some of the wooden shoe.
No?
[Henry] No.
What should I eat, then?
[Henry] Lights!
Lights?
[Henry] Yeah.
The visible sign of the invisible light?
Mmm, I don't see how I can eat light itself
'cause it's more of an idea than it is a thing.
[Henry] Cause, um, if you eat it,
it might burn your mouth?
That's a good point. That would hurt.
[Henry] Yeah.
I just have to eat something that tastes gross.
[Henry] Um... hats!
Hats?!
[Henry] Yeah.
Alright. So we're gonna have slobber carrots with drool, really gross barbecue with drool, and hats.
Alright!
Thanks for the punishment, Hank. I'll see you on Friday.